8 news now is your local election
headquarters and just
10 votes separate two candidates in one
of our local races
that's likely going to spark yet another
election the i-team's david charn is
live in studio following this today
closely david really a tight race yeah
it's a type one here and you can
actually count the difference
between these candidates right on your
fingers we're talking about the race for
clark county commissioner district c
that's on the northwest side of the
valley the seat larry brown holds right
now take a look at this
more than 150 000 votes cast in this
race
and democrat ross miller leads
republican stavros anthony by
those 10 votes today was the deadline
for clark county elections officials to
certify their vote and send it up to the
secretary of state's office
commissioners voted to certify
every race including the presidential
race except this one race here
the president did tweet about this today
now part of the reason is there are more
than 100 discrepancies
in this race those are issues like a
voter who checked in but did not vote
or issues with mail-in signatures
that's the only race in the entire
election where we have any concern
related to the outcome
and it's because of the close margin
it's a district with 218 precincts
a margin of 10 is very difficult
elections officials say a recount would
not change the outcome here so it's
likely that just this one race will head
to a special election
we did reach out to both the miller and
anthony campaigns about what this all
means
we've been hearing from everybody across
the entire district how could this
happen you know we voted for stavros
now's your chance you have to turn out
now we did not hear back from the miller
camp a date for this special election
has not been set and again
it would just be for this one seat now
today we also learned that six
people voted twice in this election we
do not know the circumstances but each
case will be sent to state investigators
and those people could be prosecuted
most importantly though
officials say the system worked out and
those votes were caught
i'm david charns 8 news now